this episode of true.you is a sponsored
by surf shock surf shock is a VPN an app
or a web extension that lets you place
your phone or laptop anywhere in the
world this thing encrypts all of your
data right so that means when you are
surfing and you've got passwords and
photographs private stuff that you would
one even want to see no one can ever say
it I could have done with this a year
ago I know no internet eventually though
we got there in the end thanks OSHA but
also you can watch content from other
countries you know how normally talk is
you go and click on something and it's
like this is not available in your
location yeah [__]
I've got surf shock now [__] your
location I'll be wherever the hell I
want
it's not literally obviously it's just
for on your phone it just thinks it is
you know when the football comes back we
all know that they do show the Premier
League in America you do the math you
know also Netflix is better in America
so just yeah I'm gonna be an American
today no problem bit of a lifestyle
change for me because you know the
Americans they do we a lot don't they
and I'm watching my figure now I'm on
lockdown not only that if you go away
traveling you can set your ship back to
England so you can still catch up on
stuff over here as well do you not I
mean
it's ideal at so just any other cards on
the table guys so shot of supporting us
they are helping us pay to make this
content make you guys happy and
entertain you and therefore we need you
lot to get behind them if you want to
use a VPN make sure it's this one use
the link in the description below the
promo code is Geordie in block capitals
very easy to remember
you get 83 percent off when you use my
code and not to mention one extra month
free that's 83 percent off one extra
month free and if you're not happy any
council within the first 30 days you'll
get your money back it's a really good
dealer I mean it just is I hope you lot
get behind so shock after they've got
behind doors really appreciate everyone
who does but now it's time for some true
news [__]
[Music]
welcome back to true news come back
we got Gio in the house tonight sucked
Lawrence it was a vet inevitable finally
put the real talent behind the camera in
front of the camera there no you know
this is our editor a lot you give credit
to Lawrence for that it's annoying this
is the kid who actually yeah [__] him in
the comments this is the true Geordie
face reveal I'm really the work behind
the scenes he's just the the actor
literally he's got his hand up Mouse
just making his talk not literally of
course women only thank you very much
cause or undiscriminating
will not come back through all of that
but yeah Lawrence is a germaphobe so he
doesn't want to be out attracting
disease passing on disease we're hi I'm
half Colombian was raised in Blackpool
so dude he didn't have a buff until he
was 11 years old exactly this guy is I'm
as dirty as they come just ask his
missus do you want to shout out your
social yeah follow me on instagram GL
sir Alva I'll swear visuals Baggio
that's enough once one's another's
Instagram just which snapchat all right
me okay get back in the box
everyone's planet and now you know I've
already been there done that dealt with
it well yeah it is a global pandemic
Brian yeah smash it a bits in February
before it was all mainstream when they
handled it he caught it with the left as
it was coming in we need to deal with
the coronavirus like we dealt with Nate
Diaz or Jose Aldo we must not deal with
it like we deal with Freud would Floyd
Mayweather why we allow it to evolve and
mutate and you know that we smoked it in
the early rounds bull it comes back
later compiled within there knocked us
out in a temple which is October one man
who is in a fight at the moment it's not
Lauren story isn't you hasn't got the
virus move on man within the as credit
symptom symptom mber symptoms
he hasn't been confirmed it's the
symptom symptoms
we're worried about him do send him a
get well soon message on Twitter I got
bless oh yeah I'll go all the faith in
the world in you Dave I can do you can
do come on we're gonna get better
together yeah together yeah
everyone gonna send Suites out today if
Instagram DM in whatever your character
just don't go and visit him because then
you might get yourself exactly
yeah that one that no so six Titans
managed to get himself out of jail on
the place to start the kids got asthma
obviously that's not the only thing that
did it he was facing like 40-foot bin
years he just snitched on me yeah and
that's how you got your tetanus reduced
you got it right down to like two years
and it's don't a Warren and he's like
look if this coronavirus gets me
I got asthma I could die so the option
is to get himself out on the streets
again where the Bloods could probably
kill him as well I'm not really
convinced he's gonna last that long I am
worried about this guy not on a blue VAR
man level we don't care about them that
much I mean it's good artists not but
it's not Dave [__] the only thing is I
don't know what his plan is like is he
just gonna hire a lot of [__]
security guards and be like look if
someone wearing a red bandana comes up
just tell them I'm not here oh if they
find him in the street just say now stay
within to me as my India you know
remember the rules you could catch
something and then if they get closer
then you just start coughing on them
maybe they'll just run away with that
gun can't take a chance nowadays I mean
let us know in the comments how long you
think six nine survives what where does
he go from you would people so listen to
his music even though he's snitch do you
think it's fair that he's supposed to be
fair they did [__] kidnap him problem
of money yeah threatened his life
in fact he got his sentence reduced for
was it 14 it was something like forty
nine years to one year like who the [__]
did he say job legislation like a big
lie of waiting painted like a mafia he
was the opera of snitching
you get snitched on you gets the shot
I've got a similar experience when I was
in school I cheated on a French exam on
a French exam basically and there's
quite a few people in the class doing it
and I sat next to this girl in math and
she was like I've got to take the test
today and I was like just cheat I
cheated yesterday the feed that it on
her own in the class world were all
working lose the sucks alone exactly she
got caught so she got caught and the
teacher took her outside and then she
Bates out me but she is rusong like
sucks like exactly that was it then we
want another mouth but they never
exactly and then I had to do the entire
test again so if I was one of six nouns
and makes that he snitched on if they
were to kill him I don't know how often
I blame did you think about killing her
though oh definitely this is the thing
right she was never heard from again
exactly so you be the judge what
happened there's a reason why he's on
the team that's all I'm saying
it man Scarface oh this is a nice one
Drake reveal is little kid
yeah adonis it's a good name it was a
very good name a lot of people were
quite surprised his parents so this was
the way it came out so it didn't come
out in a normal like way it came out
because he had a diss record don't have
on him by another rapper who was like
you were hiding a child let that boy
come home
yeah that song that the fact that he
just came out and went look this is the
baby mama because the whole point was
Drake was supposed to end up getting
married to Rihanna and then all of a
sudden he's got a kid with a pornstar
she wasn't a real full-blown porn star
was more like he was she Sopheap Rizal
so she's like French huge AA sponsor I
wonder a huge off say no more so
basically this is Drake's baby mama a
lot of people were giving him [__] about
it when it came out because she wasn't
Rihanna and everyone he was supposed to
marry real life is not as perfect now
Jenna means sometimes Rihanna dumps you
and a [__] French porn star shows you
some attention next thing you know
you're up there nuts and gosh exactly
and you pump one out and now he's got a
kid if you're hopping they're the best
of work yeah right and if you're gonna
do it I think this is a good choice
she's hot as [__] in my opinion it's not
really fair cuz a lot of people are
giving her like judging now really and I
think she's a good looking woman that is
what I'm talking about son very
beautiful woman
yeah get off her back for a start anyone
out there saying she's not Rihanna or
whatever not who is Rihanna only one and
anyway his little son looks cute as [__]
as well yeah this is a funny picture oh
my gosh he's already on the scissor
beautiful she looks a lot like him
Will's girlfriend and I think yeah
really yeah that's not me just to be
clear I'm not that's what you said why
is that bad no but cuz I'm all for this
woman and now you're saying she looks
like mummy it's girlfriend not ideal
okay
cheers mate alright first true news
we're gonna let him off with that people
are often asking like what happened what
what was he seeing in her that that's
what you see in enough yeah we clear it
all makes on question it now it's got a
huge oz yes [__] huge but were they
in a relationship for a while or was it
like a 1000
okay did you ever hear the explanation
you gave for it no I end up in this
situation where I you know where I don't
have the fairytale like Oh Drake started
a family with Rihanna like I didn't
marry to someone like Rihanna I think
that would be really
oh definitely this woman every man in
the world wanting her the level of [__]
in my mate and she would be out would be
uncommon
think he made the right call here I mean
not a lot of big celebrity relationships
work out because both of them is just so
busy
jay-z couldn't [__] keep it together
with Beyonce I still together that which
is like you know we all know what went
down there because my mom has had real
belief in real relationships with women
in my life like over the course of my
years that I'm sure she would expect or
be elated if I were to have God one of
the way they're talking about inside of
it because it was a porn star yeah what
I said it was like if you have a kid
with a porn star
that's different isn't it but the thing
is she never got to my knowledge and
I've done extensive research she never
took the dick on camera oh really it was
all just dancing me no to me in that
porn starlet worship goes down on only
funds especially now definitely if she
was just literally dancing naked on
video like alright it's not you know you
don't want it but a cam girl in a pawn
absolutely yeah let him off with it good
on him I think it's great that you sir
Sean the kid as well and he's gonna grow
into some money
oh yeah there's women out there who'd
fought that boy already that's the song
I'm not getting sadly on top of plovar
mine
the coronavirus has claimed another
victim that you that's why okay so he's
made up for himself there any the best
bit about this is Floyd always flexes on
his investment
yeah my investment see means getting
punched in the face for a living than me
for a lot of money but then he's not the
wolf of Wall Street you know and yet he
can't even pronounce the word epidemic
my favorite bit right is the eye
movement well I love he sees it's coming
up he's thinking alright I've gotta say
this [__] word and then he's like
what where's it where is it
I'm not good absurd is it a bit of a
hard time yeah he's had a rough time
lately so we're just having a bit of
but you know condolences to the guys
gone through a lot of [__] definitely
keep yourself safe Floyd and obviously
Floyd seeing you as well
if anyone's vulnerable to the
coronavirus Boyd Boyd oh my god every
day for me myself personally I don't
wanna be safe so joy exotic apparently
has the coronavirus now this is like the
weirdest turn of like out of no way a
Netflix show becomes the number-one show
because we're all locked down and we're
all talking about this [__] now all of a
sudden the lead character who's in
prison how's the [__] virus that made
us all watch it in the first place yeah
it's 20/20 in a nutshell you could say
he locked up with six nine miners he's
done an interview from prison apparently
and which strangely does he look a bit
womanly there do you it looks a lot
younger to me that is a lie Kim I didn't
think though he's got makeup on it looks
like keith lemon doing a parody of you
actually always wore eyeliner as well in
the show he has that we're gonna do a
podcast about soon before you saw it in
the comments let's see what you had to
say I think America wants to know how
have you been since the release of the
documentary it has been like a poop
parade on prune Avenue and I am the dang
roustabout who got handed the pooper
scooper let me tell you something sir
don't just whiz in my soup and call it
minestrone Chris Meloni I didn't trust
this from the moment that I saw that
Stephen Colbert was doing the interview
that isn't your exact no it's not that's
quite clearly someone doing like a
parody of Joey like it does look like
them more but it's not him he's either
too big like this is live the live link
from the jail that looks more like David
gest that it looks Joe exactly when you
look at that picture I think it is him
you know maybe serious is obviously not
here what happened to all of these
wrinkles Brian yeah
yeah it's definitely nice and broke is
[__] I've had two boyfriends most of my
life I've had some kinky sick
I have tried drugs you know it's mental
occasionally when you watch him running
about his political beliefs you
literally hit the nail right on the head
as well with what he was talking about
like basically people having medical
marijuana and freely and readily
available yeah they need it and stuff if
people want to use the news themself
when they're in like later on in life
and their pastor having a quality of
life it should be there right it
shouldn't be you shouldn't have to ask a
politician you shouldn't have to ask the
government he was made in some pints now
as I
would you vote with your exotic if you
were late in Oklahoma sometimes I would
just do something for the bunda and
right now I would definitely vote for
him I think he may be the reason why
turnabout is spreading I think we could
bring him out of prison and try and see
if he can stop it I would like to put
him and a group of Tigers on it maybe
that's it maybe the bats were the cause
the Tigers are the Cure if he has got
the coronavirus I hope he's alright I
kind of grew to like him even though he
wanted to kill Carol yeah of all the
people in the documentary he was
definitely the most likable this is one
thing where when I watched her I thought
I don't agree with that though I can't
say the n-word but you can get on
YouTube and watch any black man's rap
video and they're calling each other the
n-word what the hell is this
discrimination I'm white I can't say the
n-word and I can't that's where you lost
me there
yeah sorry Joe I wouldn't vote for you
on that yeah politically Joyce out is
quite interesting because in one hand
he's quite liberal you know the
marijuana thing and he's gay as well so
that's in a sense more than a brothel
and the other side he's very much like
he's a coward say the n-word there's a
cowboy but I did like the one he was
like I'm broker than [__] and I have
used drugs I thought yeah I could do I
could get with that
alright so interesting Lee the main
person who came under the most scrutiny
out of that Netflix Dog Pattaya King is
a woman called Carol Baisakhi she
basically inherit a [__] ton of money
after her husband I think and especially
because in the documentary there's a
moment where they're like asking her
what happened and she's like I wish his
body would just turn up so that I could
just say see I didn't kill him yeah and
it's like wouldn't you rather him turn
up alive Freudian slip yeah I need to
say that she laughs it really weird
times when you should laughing yeah it's
a nervous overcompensate for an awkward
situation that she just well anyway the
whole world is sort of uncovered had
dirty little secret and I've got to say
I'm leaning toward she [__] moon at
the guy especially considering he
reported her and tried to get a
restraining order put out on her because
she threatened to murder him and then he
all of a sudden disappeared
exactly but anyway she's come out and
strongly denied all of this by not
coming out and sending a new husband out
to do a video for nothing says I'm
innocent like hiding from the cameras
I'm alright this is a video for our
supporters who explain to you the
deception that took place in the making
of the Netflix Tiger King mind you this
guy is the most boring he reminds me it
allows me a lot of Prince Charles yeah
is the is the most boring bastard she
could ever meet there's only one word I
could use to describe this guy simp is a
man it disappoints me as when a man just
rips his bald suck off and goes I just
pop them in your handbag and do whatever
you say there's even pictures of him
with a dog collar on five years ago Eric
Goode and Rebecca Jaclyn approached us
saying they wanted to make the black
fish of big cats in captivity to expose
the abuse in captivity that's associated
with the cub heading schemes and how
these animals live in roadside zoos
after they're too big to pet obviously
he's gonna say that they didn't do that
but in my opinion just some degree they
definitely did that I think that's what
they set out to do he went in looking
for a cake and what he found was a cake
factory there was so much more to the
documentary the more they learned and
with so many different things that you
could take from it and I think what he
thought was in this documentary that he
thought was gonna be made he was gonna
be the good guy yeah when they said we
want to meet the new blackfish he didn't
realize that he would come under the
same level of scrutiny that they all
came under we found it maybe it would
expose things about them as well and
he'd ever thought that he was like oh
yeah well we're the good guys
yeah we have turned down numerous people
who came to us wanting to film because
we did not think that they were gonna do
something meaningful we thought they
just wanted to do something sensational
and we didn't want to be part of it on
what planet could your husband leaving
you millions and randomly disappearing
and everyone thinking you did it not be
sensational when they found out the
whole story behind Carolina's husband in
their minds they won the lottery yeah
but even then whatever way they say that
it's gonna come across like this is
Mendel it does matter how you package
that up its Mendel when they told us
that while they felt they had to mention
the disappearance of Carol's husband
done
23 years before 23 years before as if
we're supposed to the house 23 years ago
what's the big deals water under the
bridge that is yes old news that's our
big deal oh yeah just a little husband
who disappeared 23 years ago and left
his twenty million quid but it's simple
what's up as part of the car
text and background on her that it would
be done in a respectful and truthful way
not only did they lie about that it's
not that they lied about it
they just interviewed a bunch of people
let everyone have their say and then the
audience can make therapy Carol had her
chance exactly yeah and and if she
wasn't convincing enough and [__] Misha
wasn't that's on her that's not anyone
else's fault at no point did the Koreas
come on interjecting oh yeah actually we
think Carol did it like they just
literally gave everyone their chance and
the fact that she hasn't even come out
herself and done this video and she sent
a [__] [__] out to do I talk in
foreign what did Joe say she gets
everyone else to do our dirty work for
her for all we think Joe's nuts he's
being proved right you see the I believe
in Russia I didn't threaten them see
that oh oh
tongues dying to get up and go I did all
that thing but yeah there's nothing
behind the eye there's no real emotion
that and there's no sort of like or am
or not remorse but you know it's not
totally right in bristl point out and he
goes like if you've been married that
long you'd speak about them as if you
cared about at no point does she ever
speak about this dead husband as if she
cared about yeah at all and even the
point where in the documentary she talks
about the the meat grinder and she's
laughing saying I couldn't even get his
head in there never mind a full body and
it's like I want to kill him yeah we
start with us this week Kim Kardashian
tweeted asking followers if they thought
Carol killed her husband if she were to
come and spend an hour with Carol I know
she would have her answer and I know
what it would be cause she'd be dead do
you remember Ted Bundy
charismatic I had women eating out the
palm of his heart murderer right it was
a really nice guy [__] serial killer
so you know the fact that Carol can be
nice for an hour doesn't prove [__] mate
in 15 years of living together we have
never had an argument that makes [__]
off no I'm sorry I can't go 15 [__]
days with a woman without all human does
either one or two things going on here
you see the [__] lion or he's in a
relationship where he doesn't feel like
he can he can answer our back and we've
seen evidence of that which isn't really
a real relationship nah there must be
something that he's getting from it as
well now we know that Carol
and all that money from done so maybe
that's a you know that's the point
unless he's a [__] volunteer as well
as he I saying he a gold digger all
right so we're all living in lockdown at
the moment and it's up to the big
celebrities to reinforce the message of
staying at home and not spreading the
virus so a good example drew most of the
celebrities are doing a great job of it
all but one Aston Villa star Jack
Greeley's decided [__] all that I'm
going out he's not a good time
well we're all citing you know behaving
ourselves bless him he needs to let you
say don't you know it's stressful being
a multi-millionaire in these hard times
and he went and crush these carpets and
park cars but don't worry about it
cuz he's sorry hi everybody um I just
wanna do a quick video message just to
say how deeply embarrassed I am by about
what happened this weekend you still
have all of our blessed beer with him
it's a bit
yeah we're stressed now I know it's a
tough time for everyone at the moment
being locked in doors for so long and
obviously just got a call off a friend
asking to go around to his and I
stupidly agreed to do so you're not
listened to bar a sorry said very
specifically if your friends asked you
to beat up tell them new I don't want
anyone to make the same mistake that I
did in song obviously urge everyone to
stay at home and follow the rules and
the guidelines of what we've been asked
to do he gives this biggest teenager I
vibe off like you know and like your
mothers having a go at you all right mom
yeah like he just can't be off now know
for a fact I'll be doing that in the
near future now and near future in the
near future who's gonna go out first
gonna have one last jolly and then he's
gonna go on lockdown with yes that was
fair played he got there eventually he
something specific either he's not said
I'll give it a few days yeah future of
star in April
start now mate hopefully obviously in
the near future we can all be out
enjoying ourselves again once this is
all you took enjoying yourself a bit
father even if you just went for a
couple of cons in the house yeah how
much did you have to drink in the house
in order to get into that state it's
hard to get the [__] up in the house so
oh you know jack really SH hashtag do
better so keeps our tweeted the South
shallow dramaalert NOLA
I don't know how he found this we'll
assume it was it is my own personal
searches topless selfie set from a woman
with my late daughter Ava now available
on all efan so just to be clear this
woman will not show the full picture for
out of respect for the dead I'm assuming
it's the mother on the right and her
dead daughter I'm assuming she's not
dead at the time I wouldn't think so
before they close the casket can I get a
quick peek it's my only five minutes I'm
taking the piss out of this because
she's posting pictures of her dead
daughters tits on only farms I'm allowed
to because she's putting them on only
funds and selling them for money which I
think we can all agree is dark with the
hashtags milf Monday and Quarren city's
next stop idubbbz you know much better
lit early hood as new embargo came close
so in 2016 there was three big youtubers
who came together i dubs filthy Frank
and Maximo fur and they used to do that
sort of like shot comedy whoo so that
make cakes where they'd vomited it in
start or broad New Hope's basically yeah
they were like that Brody before Brody
I don't off that and became very
successful doing a series called content
cop where he basically taking YouTube
and break them down and basically just
say all the bad things I've done or
whatever he was defenseless like he
could he could say anything and no one
could really come back at him because he
would do anything my people like them or
not
oh yeah yeah following he didn't want a
keemstar Gibbon on rice gum did a very
famous one with Tana Mojo's in that I
think I heard about yeah and what would
happen is when these content cops would
go out a youtuber would then lose
hundred thousands of subscribers of all
the content cops the most popular one
was a youtuber known as leafyishere
who was the first like commentary
channel did he just destroy who
basically just destroyed his career to
the point where he actually left YouTube
completely now I'm pretty sure at the
concert cut was the main reason behind
that so after slamming everyone else and
basically being this guy when no one
could come at him his girlfriend started
only fans account
yeah if you're gonna be bulletproof you
have to actually be bulletproof and when
your girlfriend's person are [__] per
se yeah on only funds bulletproof then
everyone can not over your girlfriend
yeah so a lot of people haven't about
him I think a lot of these fans are
saying that he's betrayed them so yeah I
personally don't have a problem with it
most girls are posting bikini pictures
on Instagram and if I wanted to I could
just not over them whenever I want it
doesn't have to be a naughty fads and no
money needs to change hands
I could not over any girl I want none of
you can stop me from doing that so if
she's not only fan she is encouraging it
I'm not gonna deny that this is
definitely part of the transaction yeah
but to have a go at him maybe he's
brought this on himself on them I think
people have finally found the weak spot
because these ears like and a bit
defensive over it in some ways it means
you sure in a bit of oh you made a whole
video about it yeah hello everyone
welcome back to another episode of
idubbbz complains this is a very special
episode where I get to tackle two topics
that I've recently become very
passionate about a section of my
audience who thinks they know me and my
opinion on sex work quite a funny guy oh
no he is already yeah I like the
delivery there's a powerful tush I don't
put that out there I feel like you could
blow up a building someday it looks a
bit like a bomber doesn't it yeah my
girlfriend started an only fans account
which is a website where you can upload
amateur porn anything from double
penetration all the way over to lewd
cosplay can we see his girlfriend yes
for context I'm not a pervert so this is
her yo man
she's cute yes cute she's like an e girl
I guess I absolutely so yeah I can see
how he would have met her
you know there's them two looking very
cute together having a good time you're
a nice-looking couple I mean yeah he's
making I wasn't saying that yeah so this
is the type of thing that they're gonna
want to say then isn't it so a lot of
people having to go and as I mentioned
before the youtuber that he'd destroyed
the career of leafyishere uploaded a
video after I think three years of being
offline and this is the video that went
out my girlfriend started an only fans
account and I think all of it is cool
yeah I know I did you're a [__] cook
so this guy basically destroyed his
career and he decided to come back after
three years to make this 30 second video
in which he's using a free trial of Sony
Vegas because the local watermarks
they'll bounce it around and and decided
this guy destroyed my career I'm just
gonna go back on YouTube and I just one
last dig aim for this that's the kind of
[__] hosiery we can all get behind this
guy ruined your career but you think you
know what it is I'm gonna take 30
seconds just to see a [__] you man I'm
not on either side good luck the ball
for them but I do like that good on them
the plot thickens when idubbbz
girlfriend years ago had been tweeting
leafy so this is back in 2016 when leafy
was at the peak of his sauce rain saying
things like do you swallow though and
why am I never in your videos do I need
to lower the cost of money to get me to
bend over oh yeah magis all these old
tweets have resurfaced so Calvin leaf
his real name is finally got his revenge
he's had the last laugh yeah and he who
laughs last laughs the [__] hardest
be patient for that though I respect
leafy he's finally come up I don't know
yeah but good on you you know and good
look at content cop kid whoever so a few
weeks ago on on a previous episode we
did Norris forest doing something that
might have been a mistake I'm shaking
hands consider I was at a hospital the
other night where I think they were a
few there were actually a few
coronavirus patients and I shook hands
with everybody you'll be pleased to know
and I continue to shake hands and didn't
work out very well chill I didn't work
out well yeah he's got the virus should
have washed his hands shouldn't should
have kept the to me as in actual fact
probably could have let one or that this
[__] was around in February when I got
it and then maybe I wouldn't have been
mixing with people and [__] probably
spreading it I'll probably killed five
people at least five people I'm but
never mind we'll never know no way you
spent your James they've done the clap
for carers or the clap for the NHS in
the UK in Italy I don't know if you feel
from outside the UK we're all supporting
the nurses the doctors the carers
everyone sending our love and support to
them through the claps and literally
when you open the doors all up and down
the country is psyched it roars yes
[__] great isn't it what's quite nice
about it is the fact that we've never
been as isolated this before yet so
United in some yeah I do like that and I
think it's great that the NHS are
finally getting the appreciation that
it's deserves after the Sharks have been
sick with nothing for years I just hope
people appreciated enough to actually
pay them what they're worth now you know
I mean show them the money you know the
politicians out there because now you
realize how far did we [__] need them
but a side note alright we've done
doctors and nurses and we're all happy
for them but it is time to move on I'm
afraid I've seen a second clap the other
day I was like what about the real
heroes yeah what about the ones
entertaining you lot from your [__]
beds from your couches fabulous putting
smiles on the faces of the kids who when
the doctors and nurses wash the hands we
can do normal who do you call
influencers yes me yeah ksi big star
clap for care sorry when's that gonna
happen probably never sort yourselves
out next Tuesday I want to say a hashtag
it clap for ksi Priorities come on if
you can't save that child
we're the ones you've got to put a smile
on the dyin child's face Oh
make a wish you got to pay me for it
well I'm excited to do it for free it's
a doctor's time free I don't [__]
things so that's all that's exactly how
not only do we keep you entertained from
your home would tell you what the buyer
is well you wouldn't have a [__] clue
what to buy if we didn't see a swipe
book now 15% off you wouldn't have a
clue so clap for the real heroes cut for
influencers you'd be lost without this
right now alright so last week we saw
Conor McGregor demand full lockdown in
Ireland following the corona virus
outbreak since then he's made a
follow-up video hello everyone hello
Ireland we have now entered a more
substantial lockdown and I am pleased to
see it you see if you do not enter the
game you cannot win it you think this is
scripted yes I want a pizza I think I
prefer it just to be a bit more loose
yeah the way the game we cannot win it
I'm pleased to see it makes me feel on
edge from where it's almost like he's
struggling to see the Yurok you Israelis
a bit you just relax me to get out we
must encourage home workouts and we must
encourage healthy immune building
nutrition plants
I like Connor right for all our
criticized in the past I do I [__]
love watching him fight and I'd miss
Joanie
but I do think rich people just [__]
forget some aims like so much and you're
just like stood and you've just lost
your job you're unfair or whatever yeah
young got your full wage and stuff like
that and you're like yeah I'm going to
start putting them in nutrition for me
Heather and like homework oh that's when
I've got a [__] you know a small flat
living like I don't know he's sitting in
there and it's [__] huge McGregor
Sports & Entertainment gym like everyone
should be asking their chefs to make
them the best nutrition everyone should
be utilizing their home gyms we need
small space exercise programs available
to the public and we need it for all
levels of fitness
I suggest bodyweight work the need for
no equipment there are amazing workouts
to be had here he's hot in the right
place and there's not really many sports
stars come out and said anything like
this real a lot people look good to
McGregor I mean in Ireland especially
there's a lot of young people I'm sure
what do we do what do we do Connor
Connor will look into you for the
answers man so it's pretty old news now
yeah so this is old news yeah I agree a
lot of people have said to me in the
past you've got to get this admitted in
Fela on the podcast and I just don't
watch his programs for no reason
particularly I'm not it's not
necessarily Bardot's never got around
the way it so this was my first
introduction after everyone said get
them on the podcast and in my head I was
like [__] me I've dodged a bullet there
I still out traveling the world yes
am I still shaking hands yes am I still
cuddling fans at the airport
yes the guy was in the SAS I'm all for
supporting the troops and some weather
but the way he was just like digging
himself up there was David Brent am i
washing my hands and keeping my hygiene
to a high standard as always yes my
grandparents both in bed suffer him
drastically yes putting them up the life
of my loved ones at risk yes
do I give a [__] now has my life changed
no am I going to let some disease
Cobin 19 dictate my life the way he
mocks it worries me yeah some disease
Tom as a funny thing a pandemic look
I've had calls in the past order than
you you prick get out there don't change
[__]
what that he's got through this without
like laughing at any point makes me
think wow wild man the co-host on the
channel requires hospitalization god
he's got the symptoms his brother's got
the symptoms his brothers in itself
isolation his brother his younger and
fitter wild man has got asthma high
blood pressure all the things that
require people to go to intensive care I
just want to say when I first watch this
video a [__] panicked yes we heard
him on the podcast before he's
instrumental in the the Sean outwards
stories he's right Hardman weirdly saw
his Lawrence it's kind of the other way
around yeah I was panicking that's
certainly happened the wild man fear not
though he is such a tough guy he beat
the coronavirus already and you'll never
believe how he did it well he said that
struggle he gave up and he said a lot
there's people that are in way more need
than me that need those hospital beds
I'm just gonna tough it out and then a
couple days later he was fine he was
laughing about it he said he beats it
with side that drinking copious amounts
of side I'm not advocating drinking side
that as a method to cure coronavirus
just to be clear I sure that would there
his friend may or may not have beaten
the coronavirus by drinking cider but
that doesn't mean that were fried anyone
no only it's like for you wouldn't that
be amazing
probably just wild man yeah would that
be amazing if cider was actually the
cure if I'm being honest what I think
might be a little bit
likely hear me out on this is a wild
crazy alternative theory he never had
the coronavirus he was just a bit run
down a bit he'll know and just kept
drinking feels fine
never had it there you go that's
probably more likely however I'm not
gonna take that W away from wild man you
beat the coronavirus rider clap for a
wild man yeah yeah I'm not advocating
drinking cider as a method to cure
coronavirus so this is food we have five
days ago just to be clear what I'm
looking for here is any signs that you
might not be being safe Tyler because we
want him to be safe he is a bit at risk
isn't he why's that because he's big and
this is coming from me because it
[__] kicked my ass the coronavirus so
I keep it sort of live and do you know
why it's because I know whether to buy
dad Newman's Own it's the Italian
sausage and uncared pepperoni the
eyelids look into quiet heavy I love
this yeah he's looking a bit tired he's
looking like his immune system might be
a bit weak so he can't grow new is that
means he's adhering to social distancing
exactly that's good that's what we want
the water it's up to the what whether he
might not have said what we think he
said that might be Bostonian slant like
so in England they used to be a racial
slur used by some people to describe
people from Pakistan yeah and their
shops that they owned especially in the
Newcastle I'm ashamed to say if it was
it was the times right things obtained
that will say you know we say corner
shop that's what you're supposed to say
yeah it did sound like he used the same
phrase I used to hear when I was growing
up on the estate too used to use never
never all right the [__] I would think
what it is is that might be a name for a
shop in Boston I guess or America I
don't know I don't know he's racist look
in the background so we're in his room
now is there anything in the background
that may suggest not does look like a
potential swastika
I love the fact that he when he eats
food you know six three bites and when
he drinks he does it the same yeah three
gulps he takes his time it's a dominance
thing he loves an alpha male
he is the alpha is alpha [__]
meal love all time he should be in the
ER see who would be a good matchup in
the UFC for all Tyler do you remember
Roy Nelson yes that would be a great
fight Habib's out we got a new headline
if at UFC t4 now - I got Roy Nelson
versus food reviewer Carroll Baskin
versus joy exotic dasty may make them
has the Valentina I don't know if we
heard it in the video but the oven is
preheated let's go and get the pizza in
the oven
Oh forgive me said that actually I don't
know why that's so funny but it is is
you know what I mean like it's away when
the ovens really but you know let's get
a pizza in there I almost feel like
we're on a date with feeder varieties
yeah I feel like he's romancing us with
cheap beer and a cheap pizza and I'm in
loving it it smells great - it smells
real good
he's gone through nearly a full slice no
review yet just not his taking it in
he's taking it in this is the most I've
ever seen a beat without even get
passing any judgment like I said good
amount of pepperoni that's always a plus
you want to have good pepperoni coverage
I've never heard anyone of my wife's is
aware you are a good pepperoni coverage
I do one double with the fire in the
belly is dying down and it's more just
about eating rather than reviewing let's
get that balance yeah eating to review I
want 5050 I want you to enjoy the food
but I want to enjoy reviewing the things
that we need to know if it's a Buy or if
it's not this is just that crushes like
cardboard as high as energy we've seen
Tyler but God bless them I hope he's
doing all right
well portal has probably been driving
around looking for a fast food chain is
open every Western you know I just think
you get some frozen pizzas what going
well hope you've enjoyed this episode of
true news we don't know when Lawrence
will be back so don't [__] ask us
yeah I almost feel a bit like a
substitute teacher you know your main
teachers not there so you feel like you
can just have a go be nice to junior in
the comments as well because he's the
one who often you know has to block you
guys so if you want to be around one
here it will be him just getting rid of
you swatting you like flies popping you
like spots do you know me I've always
been here it's into news I have been in
the background she didn't know it now
now the face has been revealed so if
you've been blocked on Twitter it might
be thanks for watching guys don't forget
to hit that like button stay subscribed
thank you for all is editing and now I
was presenting
do you think he did a great job hobbies
do as well and we'll see you on the next
one